son los ojos de los soldados ucranianos
en el campo de batalla este hombre es
uno de los comandantes de un escuadrón
de pilotos de drones operan aviones no
tripulados de reconocimiento así como de
combate muy próximo y trabajamos bien
noche los observamos determinamos su
ubicación exacta volamos y atacamos a
veces nos oyen porque algunos drones
tienen un sonido reconocible cuando oyen
ese sonido entonces podemos verlos huir
despavoridos tumbarse esconderse pero no
todos lo consiguen
juanes peones vuk su unidad es ahora
capaz de fabricar sus propios drones de
ataque como éste dice que las tropas
rusas se han adaptado desde entonces
robots en webs nuestro principal reto es
la falta de equipamiento tenemos que
reconocer que nuestro enemigo trabaja
muy duro y es muy bueno en las contra
operaciones en la guerra electrónica así
que casi todos los días perdemos equipo
por eso seguimos pidiendo apoyo lo
necesitamos y vemos que llegan nuevos
equipos de todo el mundo como yo tengo
aunque entreno todos los vuelos diarios
sobre la capital confirman que las
fuerzas rusas han tenido dificultades en
estar
podemos ver muy bien lo que está
ocurriendo alrededor de quienes se están
protegiendo y podemos ver que la
situación empieza a ser mala para
algunos de ellos a veces quedan cortados
de sus líneas de suministro sus
municiones alimentos y combustible les
está desmoralizando y podemos ver luego
la situación en el frente oriental es
muy diferente su unidad lleva a cabo
cientos de misiones allí todos los días
y son conscientes de que la lucha será a
largo plazo